we're going to talk about the best way
to get off sugar now the question is why
is it so hard
to give up sugar well the simple answer
is
because you're doing it without your
body's help when you try to give up
sugar on top of body cravings it takes a
tremendous amount of willpower and
self-discipline
you're completely going uphill and it's
just a matter of time before you start
caving in and then going back to sugar
but what if you were completely able to
give up your addictions i'm sorry your
cravings once and for all wouldn't that
be a lot easier yes it really is because
what you're dealing with when you're
craving sugar and you're giving in the
sugar is you're really dealing with this
this spike in this one neurotransmitter
called dopamine
dopamine gives you pleasure for about i
don't know 90 seconds to two minutes and
then that's followed up with a big spike
in cortisol and then you're going to
feel stressed
personally if i ate i don't know about
30 grams of sugar right now i'd feel
like crap i'm gonna feel lethargic
for at least 20 to 30 minutes if not an
hour to two hours i just wouldn't feel
quite right i'd start feeling irritable
and grouchy
my vision would be off i would have
brain fog
i would have terrible concentration
and i would actually have more sugar
cravings but i think people are used to
it and they really don't even know how
good they can feel once they come off
sugar
but here's the recommendation on the
correct way to get off sugar number one
don't do it gradually
but don't postpone the misery
when you do it gradually you're still
having sugar cravings during this
process
so some people try to give up their
sugar cravings within i don't know one
to two to three weeks
during the entire time they have sugar
cravings i mean why not just do it
within two days and you're done
because once you adapt to ketones you no
longer have cravings they're gone
and also there's no such thing as a
sugar
detox you're not detoxifying when you're
getting off sugar
toxins are not coming out
sugar is being burned up
but what you're feeling is this
transition period
on your brain
your brain simply just does not have the
fuel it's not toxins
it just doesn't have the fuel because
you haven't converted over to ketones
quite yet there's a very simple solution
and that is to start taking ketones
in the form of mct oil
so mct oil converts quickly to ketones
it feeds your brain it makes your brain
feel happy
and you won't have that bad feeling but
you want to get off sugar very quick
very simply start consuming two meals
one at lunch and one at dinner
no snacks and just to keep this simple
just make sure your carbs are less than
30 grams per day not per meal but per
day what's going to happen is because
you're depriving your body of sugar your
body is going to start converting over
to
ketosis and your body's going to start
to use this other fuel source
and you're going to start feeling better
but the biggest thing you're going to
notice is that your hunger is going to
go away
and your cravings are going to go away
and it's not going to take a long time
to have that happen
you're looking at about two days and
then the process you're taking this mct
oil just to make it a lot easier
anyway i wanted to create this video on
those of you that are still eating sugar
despite
watching all my videos week after week
as well as those people that are new to
my channel
so if you're enjoying my content which i
hope you are
and you're applying this knowledge to
your health
and you have a success i would really
appreciate you sharing your success
story so click the link down below to my
website where you can upload your
success story so you can help inspire
others